Hi.
Howdy.
So let's say,
hypothetically, there's
a young man here who is
dating a young woman who
tends to lean very far left.
Sorry, before you
go any further,
is she present right now?
No, she is not.
OK good, so I can be honest.
Right.
So do you have any advice
for how this young man might
go about exposing
her to some new ideas
without the relationship
crashing and burning?
Oh, you're an optimist.
OK.
So you, my friend, are
making a very large mistake.
I'm sure she's wonderful.
I'm sure she's
supremely attractive.
I'm sure all of those things.
It depends what the
relationship is for.
Are you in it for marriage?
Or like, you actually have
to give me like-- well,
what's the end goal here?
Yeah, marriage.
OK, so if you're
in it for marriage,
then the number one thing
you must have in common
with your spouse is values.
Interests come after values.
But most people are
interested in lots of things.
There are lots of interesting
things in the world.
Liking the same movies,
liking the same art,
virtually worthless.
What is important is that you
have the same value system.
So politics are a
reflection of values.
Now, there are a
lot of people who
never connect their
politics with their values.
So you have to determine
whether she's politically left
because this represents
some core values,
or just because she's been
told a bunch of slogans,
and now she repeats
all of these slogans.
So when I first dated
my wife, for example,
my wife thought of
herself as pro-choice.
And then the more that
we discussed the issue,
it became very clear to her
that she was actually pro-life,
and hadn't really considered
the issue in a serious way.
It was just, she was
told on college campus
that it was a good
thing to be pro-choice.
And so she said
she was pro-choice.
And the same thing was true
of gun rights, for example.
She didn't know
anything about guns.
She'd been told guns were bad.
And then, when I explained
gun rights to her,
and when it turned out
that her father was
a member of the military,
then she shifted a little bit.
Politics is the
tip of the iceberg.
The question is whether
your girlfriend's politics--
or this unnamed person's
girlfriend's politics--
are a floating bit of flotsam
on the top of the ocean,
or whether there's actually
a structural underpinning
for what she's thinking.
So you first have
to determine that.
If there is a structural
underpinning, and if she really
believes this stuff
on a strong level,
you're really going
to have to think about
whether this is something
you want to go through
for the next 80 years.
Because when it comes
time to raise your kids--
forget about you.
OK, in my view, marriage
is-- marriage, not
relationships-- marriage is
about bearing and rearing
children.
Ideally.
My wife and I have two children.
That is the end
goal of marriage.
That is the telos of marriage.
Marriage was created so
that we could bear and raise
our children.
And that means that
we have to have
very similar perspectives on
how we want to raise our kids.
Now, if you want to raise your
kid with traditional ideas
of virtue and
decency, and she wants
to raise your kids
with traditional ideas
of multiculturalism,
for example,
and all cultures and all
opinions being equal,
all behavior being
equal, this is
going to be a real
conflict when it comes time
to parent your kids.
So you have to ask
yourself two questions.
One, is she movable?
And two, if she's not movable,
what is your end goal, here?
Because you know, there's
lots of fun to be had in life.
But when it comes
time for marriage,
marriage is-- as all the
married people in the room
know-- marriage is
not the time for fun.
You know, when it comes
time for marriage--
not totally true.
I love my wife and we
have a great marriage.
But-- see, I know
she's watching.
But when it comes
time for marriage,
it is deeply important that
you put values before all
of the other ancillary things.
If you have values in
common, your marriage
can outlast anything.
If you don't have
values in common,
then the first break,
and the the thing's over.